we already know about the Russian hacks
of the Democratic National Committee and
how those hacks were used to hand pick
certain leaks an attempt to tilt the
election in Donald Trump's favor a
Virginia Senator Mark Warner the highest
ranking Democrat on the Senate
Intelligence Committee who's
investigating Russian meddling in the
election says that the Russian
government hired a thousand people to
create fake news articles to help Donald
Trump Russia had these people working in
a facility in Russia creating fake
anti-hillary news articles targeting
voters in swing states and at a press
conference on Thursday
Warner actually said quote they were in
effect taking over a series of computers
which are then called botnets that can
then generate news down to specific
areas Clinton is sick or Clinton is
taking money from whoever from some
source fake news an outside foreign
adversary effectively sought to hijack
the most critical democratic process the
election of a president and in that
process decided to favor one candidate
over another another Warner said that
three states we know were affected are
Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania
what's interesting about those states oh
right Donald Trump won all three of
those states in unexpected and very
narrow upsets Warner and the committee's
chair Republican Senator Richard burr
were adamant that these conclusions are
the consensus of the committee this is
Democrats and Republicans folks not the
most shocking discovery we already knew
that Russia was interfering with the
election to help Trump and more or less
that Russia was using fake news and
troll armies to accomplish this and that
they've done it before in other
countries but it's notable that the
committee is saying hey we have solid
evidence for this Republicans and
Democrats on the committee agree that
this is what's going on and they're
going public about it and we are going
to be digging into fake news and
propaganda news extensively we've got an
upcoming long-form piece that's going to
air next week Pat I know you're excited
about it I'm excited about it and it's
going to deal with not only fake news
presently but the history of fake news
the difference between fake news and
propaganda news and I think it's gonna
be a really really good piece yeah
especially cuz now we know that fake
news clearly works I mean I was able to
influence an election
we know for sure at this point there's
certainly no evidence to suggest that
Russia hacks the voting machines for
example correct but by spreading
information some true and some not true
that was able to do it because you know
what we learned from the pedestrian
leagues for example you could argue that
was important revelations that Hillary
Clinton holds a private position and a
public position or she was for open
trade borders and the rest of it but
there's no merits to seeing this fake
news thing I mean there's no positives
to that no there's absolutely no angle
on this where we say well it's good to
hear fake stories perpetrated by Russian
trolls in swing states right there's no
counter to that or it's there's no
conversation about the source nor the
substance here because both are
completely bogus and 20 people are going
to appear before this committee for
private interviews this includes Trump's
son-in-law and close advisor Jared
Kushner burr also indirectly suggested
that the committee has spoken to Michael
Flynn who of course was ousted from the
administration after lying about his
communications with Russia so there's a
lot going on here not the least of which
is surprising so far but when we see
Democrats and Republicans United saying
yeah Russia had huge troll armies
spreading fake news in swing states
there's not even really anybody who's
questioning it I guess Trump would there
are still some people who are unwilling
to admit that Russia hacked the DNC
though even though our intelligence
community is universally saying it was
the Russians there's two views on
trolling that I've talked about first of
all but one is and it doesn't really
apply to state sanctioned trolling
there's trolls are sort of sad people
whose lives clearly must not be going
well if they're spending their time
trolling online but they can still cause
chaos and prevent reasonable
conversation from happening and that
that can be the goal of trolls and even
if they are sad people individually some
are some are some are paid trolls as you
know the effect is still significant
this is a totally different type of
trolling this is state sanctioned
trolling done in a mass way and it is
something that we are clearly contending
with it is something that clearly
Republicans and Democrats on that Senate
panel now understand happened and you
know I the trumpets
they'll figure out some way to
rationalize this away or not pay
attention to it today's episode of the
david pakman show is made possible in
part
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription
into I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS